i gotta ask you about the moon
um
so there's a there's a piece of the moon
on this table that you've given me yes
uh that we didn't have to pick up that
arrived here that's right so how did a
piece of the moon arrive here on earth
so this chunk of the moon if it were
delivered by
uh the apollo and nasa missions uh you
and i would be guilty of a felony right
now because illegal to own pieces of the
moon collected by the apollo astronauts
so don't even joke about that when you
go over to houston
this piece of moon rock was delivered
via the old-fashioned way by gravity so
this was a chunk of the moon which is
blasted off because the moon gets
bombarded by asteroids and meteoroids
some of them eject material from the
surface of the moon into space
and it will then orbit the common
moon earth system
and it will then eventually enter our
atmosphere and if the piece is large
enough and the trajectory is proper it
can land intact and this one landed with
a few uh 100 grams worth and they sliced
it up and then it was delivered via us
postal service to my house so you can
buy these pieces and actually can buy a
piece of mars you can buy a piece of
mars delivered by the same route
now what's so interesting about that
well if a piece of mars can get here a
piece of earth can get there
some piece of earth has some life forms
on it it could get there and if that can
happen in our solar system it could
happen throughout the galaxy
so i'm actually not of the opinion that
there is life elsewhere in the universe
at least technological life that we can
see i see this look of horror on your
face
um i view it
i am personally extremely pessimistic
would be extremely surprised i'm just
i'm curious by the transition
because you just said that life
could have arrived from mars or like
from planet to planet but because of the
meteorites striking and so on yeah and
then you went to
you don't think there
there might be life out there in the
universe technological life
technological life
like yeah advanced intelligence
civilizations okay
uh yeah okay so go on yeah so that's a
the generalization of what uh the famous
astronomer fred hoyle called i i know
this is a pg-13 program it's called
panspermia
panspermia and uh beep that up yeah
please and uh that's the exchange of
genetic life for material from
other reaches on earth which explains
the origin of life on earth but not the
origin of life itself which i think is a
much grander mystery and much more
interesting
how did life get here and you've talked
with many eminent people about that
i'm not going to add that much but but
just thinking about the reverse process
let's say life started on the earth
somehow
and then made its way out into the
universe is there enough time for the
whatever material went from earth via
panspermic direction you know spraying
the love gun out into the universe did
that then have enough time to incubate
and go on to a planet that could support
it
certainly not within our solar system
which traveling at the meteorite speeds
would require you know hundreds of
millions of years then looking at the
evolutionary history from bacteria to
bach
from you know
rocks to rock mononof i don't know i can
do this all day oh wow that's pretty
good how do you get from those very
simple inanimate objects to like i just
simply think there's not enough time for
earth to seed life technological life
throughout the galaxy i don't think
there's any evidence for that
you